today is Thursday December fourth and
holy it's December I mean GS news Chris
waters here to host you through a host
of today's newsea snooze in the way that
only gamespot San Francisco can the news
up front and a sheep in the back okay
remember how yesterday there was news
that target australia was going to stop
selling gta5 due to the game's
depictions of violence against women
well today kmart australia is following
suit a Kmart spokesman confirmed the
move in a statement to gamespot but did
not specifically mention the type of
content the company found objectionable
though Kmart and target are names that
US consumers know well in Australia the
two chain stores are actually owned by
another company a retail group called
Wesfarmers it's unclear where on the
corporate ladder these decisions were
made but it seems unlikely that they'll
be replicated by US retailers the re
remake of re has received a release date
and like a horrible mutant dog about to
rip your spleen out it's just around the
corner capcom announced that on january
twentieth 2015 a high-definition version
of 2002's resident evil remake for
gamecube which itself was a remake of
the 1996 original will arrive on shelves
for xbox 360 xbox one playstation 3
playstation 4 and pc heading back to the
spruced up Raccoon City will cost you
twenty bucks December 16th is just under
two weeks away and to downloadable
expansions have just asked you to save
the date first up its total war rome 2
which will unleash the wrath of sparta
expansion strap on an armoured six-pack
and slap a scrub brush on your head as
you take on Athens and explore the new
tech trees units great wonders and
iconic heroes the 16th will also bring
the release of the hollow dome onslaught
for Borderlands the pre-sequel it's one
of those challenge arena dealios so
expect new loot new character dialogue
new enemies and a new level cap and
finally the steady stream of updates for
halo the master chief collection
continues as 343 industries tries to fix
the games online multiplayer woes the
latest one focuses specifically on
improving matchmaking times by allowing
matches to start once minimum player
counts are met resolving issues that
cause false matches to be created and
making a bunch of other tweaks
next week they plan to tackle team
balance problems and the week after that
they'll be updating this peach amiibo to
have legs wait no that's a different
story this peach in vivo doesn't have
legs okay we're done thanks for watching
folks I'll be back tomorrow to round up
the top five news stories of the week
what do you think they're gonna be do my
job for me in the comments below hunting
seen the participate in our vibrant
online community love ya